the attack on capitalism ramps up
scientists fear the all right and the
media cannot get over her stays we'll
get into all of it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show quick note
upfront I thought that our one our one
of our producers Colton Haas had the
best take on the horse face situation
altogether he said that perhaps
President Trump was just using voice to
text and he said her these days and it
just messed up just it was serious fault
maybe maybe well we'll get into all of
the latest news but a couple of
announcements first first if you are in
LA this weekend comes yet political I'm
giving a keynote speech at noon on
Sunday followed by a book signing in a
town hall event with The Daily wire gang
I can't say I'm really looking forward
to spending all day with you people but
I guess it will have to be there anyway
so you may as well show up it's
guaranteed to be a great time for you
and to produce an abundance of leftist
cheer so you're not gonna want to miss
it make sure you use promo code DW
wouldn't get your tickets so they know
that we sent you we get nothing out of
it they get nothing out of it but use
that promo code anyway make sure to use
promo code DW when you get those tickets
and again they will know that we sing
also before we get into the day's news
you know there are certain ways that you
can save money that cost you a lot of
time and they're annoying this is not
one of those ways this is a way for you
to save money that will not cost you
time and will not be annoying that of
course is honey it is a free shopping
tool that automatically searches the
internet for the best promo codes every
time you buy something online in fact
honey has already saved listeners of
this podcasting average of twenty six
dollars and thirty four cents because so
many of our listeners have actually used
honey before honey believes everyone
deserves the best possible prices on all
the things they love which is why it
works on all your favorite sites like
Amazon eBay j.crew Walmart Best Buy
Groupon I use Amazon all the time I buy
books and products from Amazon all the
time honey helps me out nearly every
time it's really spectacular
I've saved significant percentages of
money by using honey they have 10
million members over a hundred thousand
five star reviews my honey is the money
saving shopper tool that everyone can
agree on get honey for free at join
honey calm slash Ben that's join honey
calm so I spent all you do is you go to
join honey calm slash Ben and you
register and then it automatically
basically uses all of the best promo
codes to get your discounts go check it
out join honey calm slash Ben honey is
the easiest way to save money without
shopping online use honey go check it
out right
now all right so I want to talk about a
broad issue that is now happening in
American politics and that is a sudden
lack of interest in or enthusiasm for
capitalism the greatest system of
markets ever devised by mankind free
markets which have raised half the globe
from abject poverty in the last thirty
years ole marse which have created the
kind of prosperity in which you get to
sit there and enjoy entertaining shows
every single night from people like me
just by sitting there I didn't just
imagine a world 150 years ago where most
people's homes were lit not by
electricity but by candle light where
heat was not a thing where people died
when it was cold outside and died when
it was super hot outside
when disease was rampant when
entertainment mainly consisted if you
were lucky if you were lucky of reading
around a fire but very often consisted
of less than that I mean the reality is
that your life now is so unthinkably
great in terms of material prosperity
that if somebody were dropped into 2018
from 1870 they would literally not know
what had happened they would think that
they were on an alien planet inhabited
by a species similar to the one that
they knew back home but in an area of
complete material prosperity they would
think they were almost literally in
heaven remember what one in three kids
one in four kids and families were dying
in large swaths of Europe and child
mortality in the United States was a lot
higher I mean today you have a baby you
can pretty much expect that baby to live
till the age of 80 yeah this is amazing
amazing stuff and that has been brought
about by free markets and capitalism and
entrepreneurial ISM so naturally that
means that we're now going to eat free
markets capitalism in entrepreneurial
ism we're going to dump all over them
and there are a bunch of stories today
along these lines the the top one that
comes to mind is there is one from Kim
Kelly over at Teen Vogue now this is an
older piece it's from April of this year
but Teen Vogue tweeted it out again
yesterday it should be noted Teen Vogue
is supported by ad dollars and they make
all of their money by running stories
about the latest products that you can
buy but they wrote and they ran a piece
called what capitalism is and how it
affects people and the tweet from Teen
Vogue was why capitalism
to end hey Kim Kelly wrote this at Teen
Vogue they're trying to teach teenage
girls this capitalism is defined as an
economic system in which a country's
trade industry and profits are
controlled by private companies instead
of by the people whose time and labor
power those companies the United States
and many other nations around the world
are capitalist countries but capitalism
is not the only economic system
available throughout history other
countries have embraced other systems
like socialism or communism so it's
important to explore what capitalism
actually is CNN recently reported that
66 percent of people between the ages of
21 and 32 have nothing saved for
retirement however according to salon
the reason many Millennials haven't been
investing in mutual funds or building up
their own financial nest eggs isn't
because they're too broke or that they
lack personal responsibility it's
because they think our current economic
system capitalism will cease to exist by
the time they are in their 60s in other
words they think that somebody else is
going to come along and pay their bills
Bernie Sanders is gonna come out of the
sky and pay their bills capitalism has
become markedly less popular among the
younger generations with the Washington
Post noting in April 2016 that in one
survey a majority of young adults aged
18 to 29 said they rejected it outright
and this article goes on to try to
explain where capitalism comes from they
say that capitalism is evil because
individual capitalists are typically
wealthy people who have a large amount
of capital invested in business this is
false
okay the individual capitalists are
anyone operating in a free market system
and selling their labor or their
products of their labor that is a
capitalist anybody who is involved in
the free market is a capitalist you
don't actually have to be the person who
is hiring somebody else in order to be a
capitalist as long as you are investing
your capital even in buying products
that makes you a capitalist hey but she
continues these are the people who
benefit from the system of capitalism by
making increased profits and thereby
adding to their wealth a capitalist
nation is dominated by the free market
which is an economic system in which
both prices and production are dictated
by corporations and private companies in
competition with one another again false
capitalism is a free market system in
which prices are dictated by what
competitors are willing to sell and what
more importantly consumers are willing
to buy if you are in a business where no
one wants your product you don't get to
set the price where you want to set it
if I could I would sell this podcast for
a million dollars per listener I cannot
because the market does not bear that
the same thing is true in your business
as well but these basic
misunderstandings about the free market
leads to the idea that the free market
is somehow Oleg ARCIC when in reality
the free market is the most democratic
system of property ownership ever
devised by humankind and says that you
are the owner of your own labor and your
own time it says that you are the owner
of the product of your own hands but
according to Kim Kelly at Teen Vogue our
great economic clear-thinking source
she says the capitalism places a heavy
focus on private property economic
growth freedom of choice and limited
government intervention all of which is
true generally these tend to be toward
the right of the political spectrum and
then she says how does capitalism impact
people well it depends on whether you're
a worker or a boss if you own a company
or employer the workers capitalism may
make sense but if you are not then it's
bad for you that's a bunch of nonsense
ok capitalism again has raised the globe
from an abject poverty it's the reason
why you have cool stuff today so why do
people oppose capitalism well
anti-capitalist view capitalism is
inhuman anti-democratic unsustainable
deeply exploitative and say it must be
dismantled they see it as inherently at
odds with democracy because of how
capitalists bosses hold power over
workers in the workplace and the fact
that the more capital one accrue is the
more power they have again untrue richer
people do not have more power over other
individual human beings than poorer
people do because they can't compel you
to do anything it's when regulatory
capture takes place that they have more
power power is not just power is not
just being rich power is are you
pointing a gun at somebody power does
issue from the muzzle of a gun it does
not issue simply by verb I basic how
many times have has a rich person asked
you to do something just in your life
and you've said no probably fairly often
I'm not even talking about things
they're offering to hire you to do if
they offer you if they offer to pay you
something that is not power that is them
offering you a consensual exchange and
you saying yes in any case the the
enthusiasm for capitalism has fallen
away because everybody gets to be the
product of a capitalist system we all
get to live extraordinarily wealthy long
healthy lives because of capitalism so
that gives us the ability to crap all
over it the same way that spoiled brats
yell at their parents
spoil them we are yelling at free
markets that have spoiled us to the
latest evidence of this is also Pope
Francis talking with Michael Moore
during his weekly general audience in
st. Peter's Square at the Vatican the
current Pope is not a friend to
capitalism he's a Liberation Theology he
believes that that progressive economics
ought to be wedded to the Gospels and
therefore he has constantly talked about
the shortcomings of free markets as
though the alternative government
controlled distribution of resources is
going to be superior even though it has
not been and even the social is
supposedly socialist countries that
folks on the left like to talk about the
Nordic countries Norway and Denmark and
and all the Scandinavian countries
Sweden those are all capitalist
countries with socialist redistribution
systems piled on top of them the
question for those countries is how long
you can keep piling elephants on top of
stilts and hope that the stilts continue
to support that weight the stilts are
capitalism the elephants are socialism
it is not that the entire system is
socialism but the Pope meeting with
Michael Moore is pretty indicative of
where we are and then we have a much
ballyhooed proposal from Kamala Harris
the senator from California who is just
awful I know she's my senator she is she
is proposing a what they call a trumped
sized tax plan of her own the Atlantic
doing yeoman's work to try and suggest
that a tax plan is basically just
redistribution of resources here's the
Atlantic reporting on Kamala Harris's
new tax plan and this is the way
Democrats are going to run here the way
the Democrats are going to run is in a
way that that undercuts capitalism and
this is an example of it
here's her proposal according to the
Atlantic Harris is offering a kind of
funhouse mirror in version of the
sweeping Republican tax initiative one
that would instead of slashing rates on
high-income households and corporations
push huge credits out to middle income
and poor families the lift the
middle-class Act would provide monthly
cash payments of up to $500 to lower
income families on top of the tax
credits and public benefits they already
receive last year Congress gave a
trillion dollars in tax breaks to
corporations Harris told me that money
should have gone to American taxpayers
who Indian who need it instead of
handing it over to corporations and the
top one percent now the fact is that the
people at the bottom of the spectrum the
people at the bottom of the
spectrum are not actually paying any tax
right now they are receiving net tax
benefits okay the people who are paying
all of the taxes and I mean literally
all of the taxes in the United States
all of the net taxes in the United
States are the wealthy in the United
States in the wealthy in the United
States are paying far more than their
fair share it is just a lie that people
at the bottom of the economic spectrum
are paying the tax burden in the United
States we have the most progressive tax
system on planet earth and yes that
includes the Scandinavian countries the
lie about the Scandinavian countries is
that they are progressive in their tax
structure they are not they heavily tax
people at the bottom of the lower end of
the economic spectrum as well
because you have to pay for stuff but
Democrats don't want to pay for stuff
and as we will see as we examine Kamala
Harris is supposed to tax plan she's not
talking about paying for stuff instead
what she's talking about
is essentially forcing Republicans to
raise taxes on the wealthy or forcing us
to take out inordinate amounts of debt
that will inevitably have to be paid for
either through inflation or through
higher taxes not just on people who are
rich but on everyone on everyone as well
okay we'll talk about all of that in
just one second but first let's talk
about your second Amendment right so
there's a reason that the founders felt
second amendment was the most important
amendment because it protected all the
other amendments and you want to
exercise the Second Amendment rights are
law-abiding citizen you want to own a
gun well if you are a gun lover have you
entered to win your brand-new gun from
the US ECA yet if not what are you
waiting for you're about to miss the
deadline the gun at a giveaway ends very
soon you could get up to 24 chances to
win your gun get daily but only if you
act right now it could be 24 Kimber's 24
Glocks 24 6 even 24 a ar-15s just text
safe to the number 8 7 2 2 2 and reveal
which gun you could be taking home today
but hurry free guns are not gonna last
long today's gun disappears at midnight
today the US ECA wants to get more guns
into the hands of responsible
law-abiding armed Americans like you and
they are here to help train and protect
protectors so don't put it off don't
miss your chance text safe SAF e to the
number 8 7 2 2 2 and enter right now you
have until midnight tonight to win
today's gun text the word safe - eight
seven - 2 - before it's gone forever
that's 8 7 - 2 2 again text that word
safe
- 8 7 2 2 to go check it out right now
so Kamala Harris is basically suggesting
that this is a tax
to sign checks to people who don't
actually pay taxes this is the great lie
that Democrats and the media are
constantly telling about things like the
Trump tax cut when they suggest that
it's skewed toward the wealthy the only
reason tax cuts are skewed toward the
wealthy is because the wealthy are the
only people paying taxes in the United
States people at the lower end of the
economic spectrum are not paying income
taxes they are not paying income taxes
again the net taxes that are paid by the
wealthy they pay for ninety seven
percent of all government expenditures
okay the those in the top half of the
income bracket are paying virtually
everything virtually everything as of
2015 this was the case the top 10% of
Americans pay two-thirds of the income
tax the bottom 50% of all Americans with
an income below the median pay three
percent three percent of the total
income tax we have one of the
progressive most progressive tax systems
in the world so it's just a lie that
people who are rich are not paying their
fair share Kamala Harris really just
wants to pay off a bunch of poor people
to vote for her that's that's basically
her plan her proposal joins a growing
number of aggressive plans coming from
Democrats concerned with economic
stagnation competing to win over younger
and more progressive voters and
emboldened by the success of President
Trump they differ in their mechanisms
costs and effects but all point to the
same Robinhood goal not just raising
taxes on the rich but shunting vastly
more money to the working classes and
the poor in Harris's case that means
something like two hundred billion
dollars a year more now again it is
important to notice that in the United
States the amount of benefits that are
being received by people at the low end
of the economic spectrum it's tens of
thousands of dollars in very many cases
I mean there been a lot of studies that
are done that have been done on this
particular issue benefits received by
people who are lower income in the
United States
it's then the numbers are pretty
astonishing okay people who the folks
who receive benefits forty-nine percent
of the population as of 2011 lived in a
household where at least one member
received a direct benefit from the
federal government the number of
households receiving government benefits
has steadily risen over time and those
benefits are almost entirely going to
people who are in the lower half of the
economic spectrum so that those are the
settlements that include things like
Social Security Medicare Medicaid
children's health insurance food stamps
school lunch programs the Earned Income
Tax Credit in 2010 the Tax Foundation
found that 60% of Americans were
receiving more in government benefits
than they paid in taxes so again the
folks who are receiving the government
benefits are now the people that Harris
basically wants to give more government
benefits to now I'll explain it in one
second why this is a bad idea so to
continue with with Harris's tax plan
she's offering as much as $3,000 a year
for a single person or $6,000 a year for
a married couple on top of existing tax
and transfer programs dispersed either
as a lump sum tax refund or as a monthly
payment as many as 80 million Americans
would benefit so who is going to pay for
all of this the answer is that they
don't care that really is the answer
they say that this is going to jog the
economy because if you give a bunch of
money to people at the bottom end of the
economic spectrum this is what creates
economic growth that is not true it has
never been true what jogs economic
growth is the creation of new products
and services that create new jobs and
that also allow people to buy cooler
stuff
socialism is about freezing the economy
in place and redistributing all the pie
that's in the room the capitalism is
about expanding the size of the pie now
that doesn't mean that everybody is
going to get an equal distribution of
the pie but it does mean that you're
going to be able to generate new and
better types of hi bigger pie everything
that makes pie awesome right otherwise
you can just freeze it and distribute it
until there's no pie left that's
basically the socialist model so where
they gonna pay for all of this I love
how the Atlantic describes Kamala Harris
is proposal of course the federal
proposals would come at significant cost
in some cases on the scale of the Trump
tax cuts or the affordable care act
those are not the same thing
Trump's tax cuts are not things that
cost money they are me paying less money
into the federal government that is not
a federal cost a federal cost is used
spending my money not you telling me I
get to keep my own money it is not a
cost to let someone keep their own money
the way that this is measured is insane
suggesting the affordable care act which
is a government expenditure based on tax
receipts is the same thing as cutting
tax receipts by saying that people can
keep their own money is a sleight of
hand a fiscal sleight of hand the brown
legislation would cost 1.4 trillion
dollars over a deck
the Harris legislation would come in at
something like two hundred billion
dollars per year which means two
trillion dollars over the course of a
decade Harris has proposed repealing the
Trump tax cuts to pay for her bill but
that is not even gonna come close to
covering the kind of class she's talking
about and they're talking about
universal health care and they're
talking about free child welfare and
they are talking about or Orford free
child care and they are talking about
free college tuition none of this stuff
is going to get paid for so why why is
there all this enthusiasm for this sort
of stuff in a time when we have as of
yesterday 7 million unfilled jobs in the
United States a 4% unemployment rate and
a historically booming economy why are
we talking about undermining the pillars
of capitalism because we have shifted
our mindset in the United States and
this is really what I want to talk about
today we have shifted our mindset when
it comes to what our lives should be
like we believe we are guaranteed things
here in the United States we believe
that we are guaranteed a solid level of
living because we live here you hear
this from Bernie Sanders all the time in
the richest country into the world
should we really have people who do not
have enough money to buy all the pudding
that they could possibly want you hear
that from Bernie Sanders all the time
the assumption there being you were born
here you deserve stuff you were born
here therefore America's rich therefore
you get stuff a baseline assumption you
are entitled to things here is what you
are entitled to in a free country you're
entitled to adventure that's what you're
entitled to you're born entitled to
exercise your rights in pursuit of
adventure you get to make up your own
story here that's the American dream the
American Dream is people who are coming
from across the sea to a place they did
not know to an environment they were not
used to and building lives for their
families and creating prosperity from
the ground up the American story is
people crossing the Appalachians into
wilderness they did not know places that
had not been mapped going to areas where
they had no allies setting down roots
and trying to build towns and
civilizations that's the American story
the American story is poor folks who
have an idea and go find funding for
that idea and then build that idea into
some of the great companies in American
history that's the American dream the
American dream was never you're here
therefore we give you things that was
never the American idea and that's not
to say that we can't be generous that's
what private charity is for that's why
we need a virtuous citizenry where we
take care of each other but the American
Dream has shifted now and what we're
told by the left is that the American
Dream is going unfulfilled if you do not
have a certain standard of living
provided to you by others I'll give you
a couple examples of how the American
mindset has changed in just a second and
why it's really dangerous and what it
has to say about the future of the
country first let's talk about the
software that you're using at your
company you need to make your company
more efficient and your company's right
I'm sure but you're using software from
1997 you're still using Microsoft Paint
okay you can't do that anymore
you need to actually go out and get the
software appropriate for your business
but you don't know what software that is
which is why you need to talk to my
friends over at software advice when it
comes to picking the right software for
your business software advice has done
all the research for you their team of
advisors can point you in the right
direction so you can start working more
effectively right away and it's
absolutely free just go to software
advice.com slash Ben answer a few short
questions about your business you'll be
connected with an advisor to discuss the
best software options for your needs
talking to an advisor takes 10 minutes
or less whether you're a medical
professional a construction manager and
HR pro you name it
software advice is going to save you
time and help you make a more informed
decision and if you're an entrepreneur
or you work solo software advice is a
great way to get an expert opinion even
without the resources of a big company
and the software struggle today go to
software advice.com slash Ben to get
started that software advice.com slash
Ben to connect with an advisor for free
right now upgrade your business go to
software advice.com slash Ben go check
it out right now software advice.com
slash Ben so the American mindset has
shifted radically and you can tell this
in a couple of ways so did you ever see
the movie Cinderella Man with Russell
Crowe
it's about Jim Braddock so Jim Braddock
was this this over-the-hill boxer who
basically had played out the string and
was given a shot at the at the world
heavyweight championship and for a while
he's on the dole it's the middle of the
Great Depression he's on the dole and he
takes money from the from the federal
government after he wins the
championship he walks back into the
welfare office with a roll of cash and
he hands it back to the welfare office
and they say sir
you don't need to pay that back and he
says yes I do how many Amer
reckons today would actually do that how
many Americans today if they made the
money would walk back into the welfare
office and turned the money back over to
the law of fair office I think the
answer is pretty close to zero I think
most Americans don't have any sense of
shame or guilt about taking money from
other folks they don't have any sense
that if they could prevent it it would
be better for them not to take that
money I think people feel in the United
States that they are entitled to money
because the government is nameless and
faceless see here's one of the nice
things about charity as opposed to the
way that it works on the governmental
level the government makes it seem as
though the government is handing you the
money the government has no money of its
own the government is taking from me and
giving to you or taking from you and
giving to me or taking from the future
and giving a toss now the government is
not a repository of magical money trees
there is no money forest but the
government presents you with the idea
that there is so when the government
signs your check you don't have to feel
guilty about anything
it's just receiving free money after all
however when it comes to charity and
their folks in my community my Jewish
community who received charity they feel
terrible about it you can see that you
can see they feel terrible about it
and I think that's a good thing I think
it's a good thing I think you should
feel bad about taking charity as long as
you because that that's what's going to
encourage you to not stay on the dole
it's going to encourage you to get out
there and work it's going to encourage
you to make a move toward prosperity so
you can pay all those people back if you
see the money that you are receiving as
a as a step toward getting your feet
under you once again so that you can pay
people back that's a much better way of
viewing money and money is growing for
free and that you can just take it no
matter at any time in any place it's
just a lack of entrepreneurial spirit
and and unfortunately I think that
that's the way that we're going in the
United States that's example number one
example number two there's a lot of talk
these days but four and by the way that
this exists as well in places like
Norway so Norway which is which is
prized loved by folks on the American
left and they ignore the fact that
Norway actually has become a place where
the work ethic is starting to collapse
the Economist wrote in 2015
Norwegians have coined a verb to NAV men
need to get money from nav the state's
benefit agency now you see that you
actually see this happening where people
believe that they are entitled to things
the very fact that we call these
benefits entitlements as opposed to
benefits is suggestive of this fact
that's point number one point number two
the idea of picking up and moving we are
the most mobile site Society in the
history of mankind it is easier to get
from one place to another on planet
Earth faster than any time in the
history of humankind when we talk about
our ancestors in the United States we're
thing that people in covered wagons
taking six months to cross the country
you can do it in six hours now on a
plane and for significantly less cost
and yet we are now less mobile right
fewer Americans are actually leaving
their hometowns I mean it which is which
is not a good thing we actually want
people to go out there and seek
adventure right now Americans are moving
less often than they were right this is
an article from the New York Times the
typical adult lives 18 miles from his or
her mother according to an upshot
analysis of data from a comprehensive
survey of older Americans over the last
few decades Americans have become less
mobile most adults do not venture far
from their home towns well part of that
is because a family I live very close to
my parents but if I were to move my
parents would probably follow me not the
other way around if I want to live close
to my family
you know you have to follow prosperity
you have to follow adventure you have to
follow the call you have to move but
Americans don't feel that way anymore
Americans feel like they are entitled to
a job in their hometown where they grew
up at the factory where their parents
were that is not the way the human
beings have worked for literally all of
human for literally all of human history
and yet now we believe that in order to
facilitate people being able to stay
where they were originally based we have
to shift the way that the free market
works well that's not that's not correct
and again this is not coming out of a
place of lack of sympathy this is coming
from a place where I sympathize with
people's plate and the question is what
can you do to make your life better
Democrats folks on the Left they like to
talk about what can we do to make your
life better and the answer is very
little the real question is
what can you do to make your life better
because every successful person on
planet earth is a person who at some
point said to themselves what can I do
to help myself America is a country of
people saying to themselves what can I
do to help my lot in life what can I do
to be more ambitious what can I do to
stretch my wings and fly and then we say
okay well what can we do to provide that
wind what can we do to get all the
obstacles out of your way what can we do
to remove the barriers that's the
American Way it is not the American way
to say listen you know it's
uncomfortable to stretch your wings it
may be difficult to leave home it may be
hard to do this but you know so we're
just going to make sure you don't you
never have to when we are going to
coddle you we're going to make sure that
you are suave in the warm blanket of
government benefits we are going to
ensure that you never have to get out
there and fly again this is not coming
from a place of no sympathy this is
coming from a place of you can't
innovate your children you can't
innovate your communities and you can't
innovate your country on the basis of
empathy alone and that is the best-case
interpretation of what exactly Democrats
are doing here the worst case
interpretation is something much more
cynical the purposeful enervation of an
entire sector of the population
specifically to gain votes in there by
political power and after you look at
towns like Detroit it's hard to imagine
that's not what's been going on there
for decades because the failure of this
sort of of thinking is evident in major
cities and counties across the United
States if you actually want to
reinvigorate the American spirit we're
going to have to teach people the same
lesson that God taught Abraham at the
very beginning of the Bible right get up
leave the home that you were born in and
go to a place you do not know that's how
we become bigger that's how we become
better that's how wives become better
that's how the world becomes better
that's how trade becomes better it's why
you have cool stuff it's why cultures
become better because they experience
and bounce off of other cultures now
this notion that we can hunker down now
because we've reached paradise and all
we have to do is hunker down and live
and redistribute what's in our backpacks
those backpacks are gonna run out yeah
this is not the way any of this works
okay so in just a second I want to talk
about this fascinating article in The
New York Times about why
scientists are now attempting to avoid
actual research out of fear of the
alright but first let's talk about the
clothes that you are wearing so dudes
if you travel for work and you're
looking for small comforts to make your
trip a little bit better you need to
check out the Perth performance pullover
from Peter Millar first of all I have a
bunch of Peter Millar clothes they are
just awesome I mean really slow they
they're slick looking and they are
really well tailored and they and they
look great and they happen to be
supremely comfortable the perfect
performance pullover from Peter Millar
is particularly awesome it feels great
it looks great it is super convenient
and it barely takes up more space in
your bag than a water bottle so if you
get a little cold on the plane you throw
it on to help cut the choke Plus even
after sitting for hours on the plane the
purse will look crisp and fresh and not
wrinkled and I wear mine on planes I
mean it's one of my favorite things to
bring on trips with me
do yourself a favor get a Perth pullover
today you will definitely thank me head
over to Peter Moeller comm slash Ben to
get your Perth today be sure to use my
link and you'll receive complimentary
shipping and a free hat as well that's
Peter Miller mi ll AR comm slash Ben
it's not just the pullover by the way
I've got Peter Millar shorts that are
really stylish and comfortable I've got
a couple of shirts that are
great-looking shirts from here Millar I
have a pair of slacks from all their
stuff is just terrific go check them out
Peter Millar comm slash man and again
when you do that you get complimentary
shipping and free hat that's Peter
Millar comm slash Ben ok so we have a
lot more news coming up including a
bunch of celebrities who decided they
don't like fairy tales which is real
weird so we'll talk about that in just a
second but you're gonna have to go over
to daily wire comm if you subscribe for
$9.99 a month get the rest of this show
live the rest of mandrel clave ins show
live the rest of michael moles is
garbage show live get all of those
wonderful things
except for michael moles a show she's
not a wonderful thing it's more just
like the poop on the sandwich but in any
case get all those things for $9.99 a
month plus for $99 a year get this the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr is
cheaper than the monthly subscription
because 99 dollars a year is less money
than $9.99 a month do the math yourself
you'll find that it checks out go check
it out
leftist here's how to hold tumblr comes
with all those things plus when you
subscribe over at youtube or itunes
please leave us a 5-star review those
are the reviews we care about if you're
not gonna do that
don't leave review just five-star
reviews over to iTunes and YouTube we
have a Sunday special coming out this
week with Andrew Clavin we have a couple
more with real big names coming out in
the next couple weeks as well lots of
good stuff coming you're gonna want to
be a part of it go check
daily wire calm we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so there's a fascinating article in The
New York Times I want to talk about
because it speaks to the lack of
objectivity when it comes to the
intersection with politics the article
from The New York Times is titled why
white supremacists are chugging milk and
why geneticists are alarmed which is a
weird title and here's what they say
it's from Amy Harman nowhere on the
agenda of the annual meeting of the
American Society of Human Genetics being
held in San Diego this week is a topic
plaguing many of its members the
recurring appropriation of the fields
research in the name of white supremacy
sticking your neck out on political
issues is difficult said Jennifer Wagner
a bioethicists and president of the
groups social issues committee who had
sought to convene a panel on the racist
misuse of genetics and found little
traction but the specter of the fields
ignominious past which includes support
for the American eugenics movement looms
large for many geneticists in light of
today's white identity politics they
also worried about how new tools that
are allowing them to home in on the
genetic basis of hot-button traits like
intelligence will be misconstrued to fit
racist ideologies this is an argument
that I have on a pretty frequent basis
with a friend of mine Jane Costin over
at Vox Jane is black and and I think
rightly has great sensitivity and the
everybody should have great sensitivity
but I think Jane would suggest that her
background contributes to the
sensitivity with regard to the racist
past of the United States and the and
the racist association between politics
and bad science and so this has led to
some serious conversations was him the
two of us about political correctness
about whether in fact there's an
appropriate time to talk about IQ for
example or standardized testing for
example or about natural differences
between men and women like when can you
talk about biology without being
condemned as a sexist or racist these
are real issues that we have to discuss
and take on head-on
unfortunately the scientific community
has decided to quash a lot of actual
science because they're afraid that
people who are racists are going to take
that science out of context and then use
that to club into submission a minority
group and that's basically what this New
York Times article is about says in
recent months some scientists have
spotted distortions of their own
academic papers in far-right internet
forums others have fielded confused
queries about claims of white
superiority wrapped in the jargon of
human genetics misconceptions about how
genes factor into a
America's stock racial disparities have
surfaced in the nation's increasingly
heated arguments over school achievement
gaps immigration and policing instead of
long discounted proxies like skull
circumference and family pedigrees
according to experts who tracked the
far-right todays proponents of racial
hierarchy are making their case by
misinterpreting research on the human
genome itself and into baits that have
been largely limited to ivory tower
forums the scientists whose job it is to
mine human humanity's genetic variations
for the collective good are grappling
with how to respond now here's the real
way to respond to all of this put out
the science and then defend the science
that's the way to respond to all of us
instead
the scientists afraid that their science
is going to be misappropriated
misinterpreted or used for bad reasons
they've decided that they are going to
simply quash all of this discussion
internally John November is a University
of Chicago evolutionary biologist he
says studying human genetic diversity is
easier in a society where diversity is
clearly valued and celebrated right now
that is very much on my mind once my
doctor novembri has folded into his
recent talks depicts a group of white
nationalists chugging milk at a 2017
gathering to draw attention to a genetic
trait known to be more common in white
people than others the ability to digest
lactose as adults it also shows the
social media post from an account and to
called enter the milk zone with a map
lifted from a scientific journal article
on the traits evolutionary history in
most of the world the article explains
the gene that allows for the digestion
of lactose switches off after childhood
but with the arrival of the first cattle
herders in Europe some 5,000 years ago a
chance mutation that left it turned on
provided enough of nutritional leg-up
that nearly all of those who survived
eventually carried it and then the post
shows his snippet of hate speech urging
individuals of African ancestry to leave
America saying if you can't drink milk
you have to go back well so what I mean
so what so they're idiots and one of the
great ironies of white supremacists is
that are the stupidest people on the
planet they're constantly talking about
how white people are superior and
they're just dumb asses that's one of
the things that's so funny it's like if
you're gonna proclaim white superiority
and you really should send your best but
as president Trump would say about
Mexico they're not sending their best
okay the white supremacists are not
sending their best they're sending
idiots and then I go yeah wait white
people better than everybody else
also I scored 1100 on my SATs ISM in a
commentary that accompanied the
paper in the journal genetics dr.
novembri warned that research is wrapped
in numerous cabinets that are likely to
get lost in translations because people
are flaunting DNA ancestry tests
indicating exclusively European heritage
but the problem here is that we actually
have to look at what science does have
to say because it is a con founding
factor when you look at attributing
racism to America so take for example
racial disparities in education so
there's a lot of talk these days about
affirmative action and whether people
are performing at certain levels
eligible to get them into college and
the suggestion is that it is historic
American racism that has led to that has
led to the education gap in America's
higher education system well an
alternative an alternative would be that
the test scores do not line up equally
among various ethnic groups right they
they just don't and that's true not just
with regard to black and white it's not
true with regard to white and Asian
white people score lower on the SATs
that Asian people do as a general matter
in the United States how much of that is
genetic how much of that happens to be
environmental we don't actually know the
answer to that that's a hotly fraught
question in science but suggesting that
racism is to blame for everything
without looking at other confounding
factors like for example test scores is
a mistake and leads us to the wrong
outcomes and leads us to the wrong
measures to deal with those outcomes
genetics is not the answer to all of
these disparities but neither is racism
now these are questions we have to be
very careful about because obviously you
don't want to give material to people
who are suggesting that people some
people are an air inherently or
inherently worse or more evil or more
violent or stupider because of the color
of their skin genetics doesn't line up
that way but you also have to look at
questions of science because you are a
scientist so it is it is fascinating to
watch this debate play out in real time
so there are doctors who have organized
meetings of social scientists to discuss
the social implications of the fields
newest tools David Nelson a Baylor
College of Medicine geneticist who's
president of the Human Genetics Society
says it will not stay completely quiet
on the issue they said there's no
genetic evidence to support any racist
ideology which is true because racism is
a moral view and
genetics is a scientific view and
scientific racism is the use of science
in order to be racist it is not the use
of science in order to pursue good ends
so if you're silencing research because
you're afraid of how people are going to
use that research then I would suggest
that you're misusing science and we need
to have some very hard conversations
about actual science actual problems in
actual solutions without falling prey to
the idea that because bad people are
going to misuse the information we have
to quash the information itself okay
now meanwhile I have to discuss this
these insane ridiculous stories today
the couple of insane and ridiculous
stories so number one Keira Knightley
says that she is not going to allow her
daughter to watch The Little Mermaid or
Cinderella which makes perfect sense
because she played in Pirates of the
Caribbean a woman who had to be saved by
a man but here she is and here she is
talking about she's not gonna let her
kids watch Disney movies I love how pop
sugar covers this Keira Knightley has a
strict parenting rule about Disney
movies and the reason is spot-on and
what is her reason let's hear it from
Keira Knightley and she's banned from
seeing certain children's movies right
yeah what are they Cinderella mm-hmm and
because you know she ate she waits
around for a rich guy to rescue her
don't rescue right obviously right about
because I really like the phone but
Little Mermaid I mean the songs are
great but do not give your voice up for
a man okay so the Little Mermaid is
immoral but for other reasons the Little
Mermaid is about a girl who decides to
disobey her father leave her culture and
go gallivanting around even though she
knows that her father is going to be
turned into like a neematoad so she said
that that that Little Mermaid has some
serious problems with it but Cinderella
really the message of Cinderella is wait
around to be saved by a man first of all
has she seen the modern version the
modern version is great who CA have you
guys seen the modern version of
Cinderella like Justin and send you the
the the one directed by Kenneth Branagh
it's terrific it's C terrific terrific
film it's really good and if you think
that Cinderella is supposed to be some
sort of shrinking violet you haven't
even watched the original Cinderella the
original Cinderella she's kind of sassy
you go back and you watch it it's
actually true but this idea you women
can't be saved by men women save
yourselves listen women should be
independent women should save themselves
also there are situations in which women
need men it's called all of human
history and there are situations in
which men need women also called all of
human history but need each other in
different ways one of the great
annoyances that I have with some of the
modern Disney films is that every single
Disney film is now concerned with this
idea that women are deeply independent
and they do not need a man it's one of
the reasons why frozen is much more
popular with critics entangled was even
though tangled is by far the superior
movie because tangled is is about yes an
independent young girl but also about
the guy she falls in love with who has
to actually perform heroic feats in
order to help her that's okay that's
good for boys and guess what that
doesn't mean that girls can always count
on guys to save them but when evil is
afoot in the world it is typically men
who are going out there to meet the evil
with a sword or a gun let's let's not
pretend that all gender roles are the
same now I'm gonna say something deeply
controversial men and women are
different I know very controversial and
fairytales tend to embed these ideas
that men and women are different that
women are largely composed by evolution
to help build and men are largely built
by evolution to help protect and defend
all right that this is this is the
difference between men and women men are
built to destroy things they can build
things too but only when they are doing
so for the purpose of cultivating a
family or cultivating a civilization
which is where women come in right women
helped build civilization by helping to
tame men men helped build civilization
by being tamed by women and also I mean
that's what the taming of the shrew is
really about and also and also by
basically changing their destructive
tendencies toward toward growth
reinforcing those things is not a
terrible thing how many women have
watched it like really how many women
have watched Cinderella and really been
damaged by it how many women have
watched it like is there is there a
woman who watched Cinderella and then
she was like you know what I'm just
gonna sit here I'm just gonna wait for a
dude that really I don't know what these
women are thinking and then Kristen Bell
came out and she said something very
similar Kristen Bell said that Snow
White sends the wrong message right now
I I hope that she was joking but I have
no clue whether she was joking I kind of
doubt it
she says that snow white sends kids a
bad life lesson she says every time she
says every time we close - no way I look
at my girls and ask don't you think it's
weird that snow I didn't ask the old
witch why she needed to eat the Apple or
where she got the Apple I would say I
would never take food from a stranger
with you my kids are like no and I'm
like okay I'm doing something right
well you don't actually teach your kids
that that's sort of the theme of the
story is that Snow White's an idiot
right the theme of the stories that Snow
White shouldn't be taking apples from
strangers and then she also says don't
you think it's weird the prince kisses
Snow White without her permission
because you cannot kiss someone if
they're sleeping again
I don't know how many people actually
think it's okay to kiss someone while
they're sleeping cuz it's weird the
whole point of that fairy tale and
Sleeping Beauty is that the it only
works because it's true love's kiss
right she's met the prince before and he
and the idea is that love overcomes even
death that is the actual theme of the
fairy tales but I guess we're gonna rip
all this stuff away in favor of surface
messages about me too and women's
empowerment really really dumb stuff
okay so in just a second I'm gonna talk
about some things that I like and some
things that I hate so let's do some
things that I like real fast so we begin
today with a great new book out about
Babe Ruth Jane levy is one of my
favorite author she is just terrific
she's written a biography of Sandy
Koufax it's quite clear word biography
the Mickey Mantle but spectacularly good
and she's a new biography out about Babe
Ruth I love sports books and if you
enjoy baseball or business go check out
Babe Ruth and the world he created the
title the book is the big fella
by Jane Levy who is one of the best
living American sports writers she's
really really first-rate okay time for a
couple of things that I hate many many
things that I hate today
yeah so much hatred okay so we begin
today with CNN's Brooke Baldwin
you remember that just a week ago she
told Matt Lewis and Mary Katharine ham
that they should not use the word mob on
her program to describe Democrats who
were actually mobs because that would be
mean and the only real mobs are
Charlottesville mobs here she is trying
to explain herself and failing
dramatically and listen like I don't
want to be the word police and that was
not my intention
but I also believe in calling out
talking points and to hear him bring
that up I had to I had to say something
and honestly at the end of my day like
I'm sure you check your Twitter too and
if
I have worked the left and the right
then I'm done my job okay so yeah she's
she doesn't hurt the left ever when's
the last time you heard the left go yeah
Brooke Baldwin really irks me so I'm not
sure where the earth both left and right
comes from so media bias just on full
display speaking of media bias on full
display there's an article at NBC News
today by Alex cites Wald who is a good
reporter I've dealt with him a little
bit he used to work I believe for slate
is that right well now he has an article
and this article is not a good article
it is called beta mania why Democrats
are crazy for their authentically cool
Senate candidate when is the last time
you heard about a Republican candidate
losing by near double digits in a blue
state and there's a lot of talk about
how cool he was and the media were
fawning over him now this is not the
first time that we've seen this right
they did the same thing with Wendy Davis
she was the cool kid and then she lost
by 20 points to Greg Abbott in Texas and
there was John Asaf in Georgia six he
was the cool guy and then he lost in
Georgia six - karen handel
a woman I know but who's a very generic
congressional candidate who'd run a
couple of races statewide before and
lost but there were all sorts of
articles John Asaf the wave of the
future have you heard of John Ross
essence what's he been doing the best
part of that story was that John Ross
off basically got conned into marrying
his girlfriend to run for Congress like
hadn't married her for six years and
then he was like well maybe I'll win if
I marry her which gotta be flattering to
her and then he lost
oops well now that writing full articles
about Democrats are crazy for bado
or so so I what which part of it about
beta was the really great part the part
where he pretends to be Hispanic by
using the name beta when his actual name
is Robert or Roark or the part where he
drove over a median line while drunk
plowed into a truck and then tried to
drive where he was 26 which is the best
part you think about beta or Roark but
the Democrats are really in love with
him and there's this whole long article
about the wonders of beta work he's just
spectacular Jim Messina former Hillary
staffer says people are motivated by him
as a political leader and a human being
he's authentic and luckily luckily
authentically cool for him to play play
air drums to the who or skateboard is
both authentic and cool people want to
hang out with him hey
okay so here's something about people
who are authentic and cool okay well I
remember when the Wright tried to do
this with Marco Rubio and I like senator
Rubio but I remember they're like Marco
Rubio listens to rap that makes him cool
I think
okay how do you do fellow kids hey beta
O'Rourke is how many years old how old
is beta O'Rourke he's he's 46 years old
if you're a skateboarding when you are
46 years old you're no longer cool you
get banned from the city park for being
the creep okay you did it like really
he's a he's a he's a skate like at least
when Bill Clinton is trying to be cool
he's playing the saxophone or something
which is something you can do as a
middle-aged person and not look
ridiculous but if you're 46 years old
and got your long wavy hair man you're
just riding around on your skateboard
and you're playing air drums to the whoo
like the only time you play air drums if
you're if you are an adult human is when
you have children to amuse your kids
right a guy air band in the car to amuse
my four and a half year old because she
thinks that it's very funny I don't do
it in public because I'm so awesome
because I play violin in public right I
mean come on come on it's it's it's not
I don't even know I just ridiculous so
well done media just do it doing
yeoman's work Joy Behar also
contributing to the media's wonders this
week she said that Trump is teaching
Americans to be sexist racist bullies as
opposed to the media who have been
teaching Americans to care about whether
somebody is one one hunt for Native
American and teaching everyone that men
are evil and ought never to be listened
to in any case here's Joy Behar
screeching at you from the view I know
every time I criticize the view I lower
my chances of being on the show but
there's only so much I can do to to
steer clear of this particular fray this
guy is training American kids to
disrespect women say they call them
names you know to be racist in many ways
to be bullies even though it's very best
in the PISA builder yeah um number one I
think that the idea of President as
moral leader sort of collapsed with Bill
Clinton I think that's been true for 20
years if you're looking at the president
and saying I wish my child would act
like the president first of all you
should only say that you wish your child
would act like a person you think your
child should act like not based on the
position it's like saying I wish that my
travels would act like the CEO of Exxon
well it sort of depends on who the CEO
of Exxon is if it turns out the CEO of
Exxon is a good guy great if it turns
out the CEO of Exxon is a scumbag then
it's probably a bad idea
I'm always confused by people should
follow the the character of the
President of the United States I agree I
would
the president had more character I wish
the president didn't say these things I
wish he treated women better but if you
really think that Trump is what's
poisoned the well here you haven't been
watching for the past couple of decades
in American politics okay time for a
couple extra things I hate today
so Roseanne without Roseanne which the
ABC launched a show called the Connors
because they still had to make funny
still and make money without funny
actually
so Roseanne Barr tweeted out I ain't
dead because they killed her off in the
series
I guess they killed her off of a drug
overdose is that right in the Connors
well the the show was a complete
complete fail when Roseanne returned on
ABC earlier this year it got nearly 20
million viewers in eighteen point two
million viewers a five point one rating
when it when it finished it had ten
point three million viewers and a two
point four rating the debut of the
Connors started off with ten point five
million viewers and a two point three
rating so not not great and it's just
going to decline from there because it
turns out that no one wants to watch
Roseanne without Roseanne ABC should
have just killed the show if they really
felt the necessity killed the show or
they should have rehabbed Roseanne or
they should have said listen we need to
take a break from Roseanne we'll be back
in a while after Roseanne has done her
required penitence but it's the in said
they're not gonna do that they'll just
keep plugging along with the show nobody
really wants to watch that's not even a
story that I hate that much here's the
story I really hate because it's just so
idiotic
Holofernes press is now reporting that
rising us start Issa Rae held up her
hand up Wednesday to sexualizing men in
her hit television series insecure
saying it was time for the female gays
to have its day gays being like Gaz E
not like the female gays like Ellen
DeGeneres like the female gays to have
its day the african-american writer and
producer who first broke through playing
herself in the cult youtube series
awkward black girl admitted she was all
for the camera lingering longer on the
glories of the naked male okay so a
couple of things
so she says men are more sexualized in
the series because we are seeing this
through the female lens she says when
I'm in the act myself I don't take a
look at my body you're seeing what I see
what I'm looking at it's all very
intentional
we're always seeing bleep and bleep on
TNA on screen this is an opportunity to
reverse that she says that her mom who's
a good Christian hates the show should
the bad language the sex she'll say why
did I even bother with parental control
and having you not watch r-rated movies
if you grew up to make the things you
weren't allowed to watch
she said that she's basically making
porn what I think is hilarious about
this he says it's time for women to
sexualize men okay well I thought the
critique was that men were sexualizing
women and that was bad the mentioned
truth women it's pieces of meat so I
guess now there are verses that women
should sexualize men and treat them as
pieces of meat there's a difference
however when women are sexualized by men
in treated as pieces of meat they don't
like it it is one of the great
objections the correct objections of the
meats you movement don't treat me like a
piece of meat don't sexualize me don't
treat me as though I'm just a sexual
object fair enough
correct how do you men react to being
sexualized if a woman says to a man I
really want to see you naked there is
not a man on earth who's upset about
this sentence yeah like really this
isn't that men do not operate in the
same way that women do and only idiot
radical feminists think differently if a
man says to a woman in a bar I want to
see you naked she's insulted and throws
a drink in his face if a woman says to a
man in a bar I want to see you naked
the man says okay where do we go that's
really how that goes and there's a 1989
study it's still my favorite social
science study ever is a 1989 study in
which these college professors sent an
attractive woman into a bar to ask a
hundred men whether they wanted to go
home with her for the night 75 of the
100 men said yes hey then the the same
study authors sent a man into the bar to
ask a hundred women whether they wanted
to go home for the night how many women
said yes zero zero so when people win
when radical feminists are like it's
time for us to start sexualizing men
better like go for it man we've been
waiting for this for generations let go
go for it but again if you are
convincing women that you are somehow
acting in equality to men it's gonna
work out well for you it ain't gonna
work out well for you okay it's not
going to work out well for you because
it turns out you'll just be used and
abused by a bunch of men and in the end
you are not acting authentically the way
that you actually feel about sex you are
acting as people are telling you to feel
about sex and that means that you are
probably going to feel emotionally empty
afterward now maybe there are some
people who are very into the casual sex
and they like to sexualize men and
everything works out great I'm not
talking to you and I really mean you
like it's one person I'm talking about
all the other women on planet earth who
attach emotional intimacy to sex because
there's other studies that demonstrate
that women have better sex in
emotionally intimate situations sex with
strangers doesn't that work the same way
for men and women because this is what
evolution teaches us again this is not
me
subjectively trying to promulgate my
traditionalist views on sex on women
evolutionary biology is not in favor of
women having random promiscuous sex with
strangers it leads to the genetic
offspring of idiots really this is why
women are more sexually selective than
men and this is true in every sexually
dimorphic species basically so it's
again go for it you want to do this all
you enjoy but let's not pretend that
this is in any way going to forward the
the enjoyment or happiness of women it's
really really asinine okay so we will be
back here tomorrow with all the news
plus it's today a Thursday
man it's been a long week so tomorrow is
a Friday that means it's mailbag time
and you can ask all your questions so be
a subscriber at daily we're calm to get
those questions in right now and we'll
see you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018